This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. People who make horror movies know that if you want to scare someone, use scary music. And when we want to explore the design of music, we call Rishikesh Herway, from the podcast Song Exploder. So here are two fundamental ways to make something sound scary, according to evolutionary biologist Dan Blumstein. The first way is to use lots of screechy irregular tones. Well, the animals, when they're scared, are blowing a lot of air across their vocal cords or across their serencs if they're a bird. And the sounds of screams are something that is arousing and makes people feel negative.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。拍恐怖片的人都知道，如果你想吓唬别人，就用恐怖的音乐。而当我们想要探讨音乐的设计时，我们会打电话给播客《歌曲解密》（Song Exploder）的瑞希凯什·赫威。那么，根据演化生物学家丹·布鲁姆斯坦的说法，让声音听起来恐怖有两个基本方法。第一种方法是使用大量刺耳的不规则音调。动物害怕时，会通过声带或鸟类的鸣管吹出大量空气。尖叫声能唤起情绪，并让人产生负面感受。
It's biological. Your lizard brain hears Bernard Herman's knife stabbing music and psycho and says something terrible is happening right now The second way sounds can make you feel uneasy is to go the other way make really low grumbling sounds with lots of bass Another biological cube that might lead to fear and anxiety is hearing low frequencies The lowest frequency a species can produce is a function of its body size. So low frequency probably should scare you. It might mean that something big is around.
这是生物学本能。你的爬虫脑听到伯纳德·赫尔曼在《惊魂记》中那刺耳的尖刀音乐时，就会觉得此刻有可怕的事情正在发生。声音让人感到不安的第二种方法则是反其道而行之，发出带有大量低音的低沉隆隆声。另一个可能导致恐惧和焦虑的生物学暗示是听到低频声音。一个物种能发出的最低频率取决于它的体型。所以低频声音可能会吓到你。它可能意味着有什么庞然大物在附近。
Mix those both together and you're on your way to creating classic scary music for scary movies. But horror movies aren't just meant to be horrifying. They're also meant to be exciting and fun, so it's sometimes nice to have a driving beat. The music from the movie Halloween by a composer John Carbiter will always greet me out, and also get me kind of excited. In terms of horror movies, I certainly know that I respond to sound in horror movies in ways that are complex. You know, John Carbenter's soundtracks are, you know, good example, you know,
把这两者结合起来，你就走上了为恐怖电影创作经典恐怖音乐的道路。但恐怖电影不只是为了吓人，它们也旨在带来刺激和乐趣，所以有时候带有一个强劲的节拍会很不错。作曲家约翰·卡朋特为电影《月光光心慌慌》创作的音乐总是让我起鸡皮疙瘩，同时也让我感到有点兴奋。就恐怖电影而言，我当然知道我对恐怖片中声音的反应是复杂的。你知道，约翰·卡朋特的配乐就是一个很好的例子，你知道的，
that's a very specific thing. It evokes dread. David Slade is very good at evoking dread himself. My name is David Slade, I directed the pilot for the first episode of Hannibal, and I'm an executive producer on the show, and I pretty much sound mix every episode. I've been binging on the TV show Hannibal for the past couple weeks, and it really gets under your skin. It's the story of a serial killer named Hannibal Lecter who you may know from Silence of Lams and Man Hunter. This is kind of a prequel to those stories.
那是一种非常特殊的东西。它唤起了恐惧感。大卫·斯雷德本人就非常擅长唤起恐惧感。我叫大卫·斯雷德，我执导了《汉尼拔》第一季的试播集，我是该剧的执行制片人，而且我几乎为每一集都做过混音。在过去的几个星期里，我一直在狂追电视剧《汉尼拔》，它真的深入人心。这是一个关于连环杀手汉尼拔·莱克特的故事情节，你可能从《沉默的羔羊》和《猎人》中知道他。这可以说是那些故事的前传。
Hannibal is a nasty character who commits grisly and unspeakable crimes. The other main character is Will Graham, an FBI profiler who has a knack for getting inside the heads of serial killers to try to catch them. Trust me, there is nothing fun going on inside Wilgram's head, and inside Wilgram's head is exactly where the sound design of Hannibal is trying to place the viewer. Wilgram visualizes things, and he recognizes patterns, this is what he does, he reconstructs things in his head, it's a mental activity, it's an abscess firing, these are things that we want to make an audio and log off.
汉尼拔是一个令人厌恶的角色，他犯下了残忍且难以言说的罪行。另一个主角是威尔·格雷厄姆，一名FBI心理侧写师，他有一种钻进连环杀手脑子里去抓住他们的天赋。相信我，威尔·格雷厄姆的脑子里可没有什么好玩的事，而威尔·格雷厄姆的脑子里正是《汉尼拔》的声音设计想要把观众带到的地方。威尔·格雷厄姆会将事物可视化，并且他能识别出模式，这就是他做的事，他在脑海中重构事物，这是一种心理活动，是突触在放电，这些都是我们想要通过音频表现出来的内容。
So there's a lot of clink, clink, clink, clink, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click, click All the classic horror movie music we mentioned before exists outside the world of the story. In other words, it's not being heard by the character as being depicted. It's just being heard by the audience. But composer Brian Ritesle's score for Hannibal feels different. You get a sense that it's even being heard by Will Graham inside his own imagination. Our whole goal with horror really is to transport people into this other reality, and it's a scary reality. It's a tense reality, but it's a beautiful place too. But to do that, I find the most effective way to scare people is to throw
所以有很多叮当声、点击声。我们之前提到的所有经典恐怖电影音乐都存在于故事的世界之外。换句话说，它们并没有被描绘中的角色听到。它们只是被观众听到。但作曲家布赖恩·赖泽尔为《汉尼拔》创作的配乐感觉有所不同。你会觉得，甚至连威尔·格雷厄姆在自己的想象中也能听到它。我们做恐怖效果的全部目标其实是把人们带入另一个现实，这是一个可怕的现实。这是一个紧张的现实，但它也是一个美丽的地方。但要做到这一点，我发现吓唬人们最有效的方法是向他们抛出
sounds at them that are unfamiliar to them. So Brian constructs new sounds that the audience can't place to create unease. That's not a guitar. What is that? audience can't place to create unease. That's not a guitar. What is that? A lot of what we do is create all of the sound. So we turn all the sound effects off and the ones that we think are important, we try to make something that resembles that sound or feels like that sound. I don't differentiate really between ambient sounds like a motor and a bass. So in this case, he's on a motorcycle. I thought it'd be really interesting to make the feeling
他们不熟悉的各种声音。因此，布赖恩构建了观众无法辨别的全新声音来营造不安感。那不是一把吉他。那是什么？我们所做的大部分工作都是创造所有的声音。所以我们关掉所有的音效，然后对于那些我们认为重要的音效，我们试着制作出类似于那个声音或感觉像是那个声音的东西。我其实并不区分像马达和低音这样的环境音。所以在这个例子中，他骑着一辆摩托车。我觉得如果能做出
of what it would be like being on that motorcycle. Russia would adrenaline and the wind and the sound of the engine, which is underneath you. I mean, all this is very powerful stuff. So the first idea I had was to do it with an upright bass. Just glistening up and down the neck. Ooh, ooh, ooh, kind of revving. The cue starts with the motorcycle starting up, so we do lots of little things in there to mimic or hint at those sounds.
骑那辆摩托车时的感觉会非常有趣。肾上腺素飙升，风声，以及位于你下方的发动机轰鸣声。我的意思是，所有这些都是非常有冲击力的东西。所以我脑海中的第一个想法是用立式低音提琴来表现。在琴颈上上下滑动。哦，哦，哦，有点像在轰油门。音乐从摩托车启动开始，所以我们在里面做了很多小细节来模仿或暗示那些声音。
On screen we're seeing the key turn castenets, then we see the flames from the engine, the sound of heat, is me bowing a wood block. Put some reverb on it and it sounds like smoke. The more I work with the different instruments, the more I understand what you can get out of them. Almost all the sounds in Hannibal start out as an acoustic element from Brian Rytel's workshop. Then the effort is made to strip it of identifying characteristics that would ground the sound in the real world.
在屏幕上，我们看到钥匙转动时的响板，然后我们看到了发动机的火焰，热浪的声音，是我在木鱼上拉大提琴弓。加上一些混响，它听起来就像烟雾。我跟不同的乐器打交道越多，我就越明白你能从它们身上得到什么。《汉尼拔》中的几乎所有声音最初都来自布赖恩·赖泽尔工作室的原声乐器。然后努力剥离那些会将声音固定在现实世界中的辨识特征。
I'm constantly trying to de-guitar or D drum, a drum. That's Brian placing a wooden chopstick on a snare drum and pulling a violin bow across the chopstick. You could never tell by listening that a chopstick, bow, or a drum made this sound. Brian doesn't just take regular instruments and make them weird. He also takes weird instruments and makes them weirder. I went around Brian's studio as he pulled out examples of the instruments he uses. For example, the sound of synapses firing inside Wilgram's head started out as a Newton's cradle. If you don't know a Newton's cradle by name, you definitely know the sound.
我一直在试图“去吉他化”或“去鼓化”。那是布赖恩把一根木质筷子放在小军鼓上，然后拉动小提琴弓划过筷子。你听绝对听不出来是一根筷子、琴弓或鼓发出了这个声音。布赖恩不只是把普通的乐器变得古怪。他还把古怪的乐器变得更古怪。我参观了布赖恩的工作室，他拿出了他使用的乐器样本。例如，威尔·格雷厄姆脑海中突触放电的声音最初是一个牛顿摆。如果你不知道牛顿摆的名字，你一定知道它的声音。
Right, everybody knows this. It sits on your desk. You know it's that pendulum toy with the stainless steel balls hanging from strings. But what I did is I used it as a, I used it to create these rhythms, um, uh, synapse in your brain stuff. And, and did some different treatments of those and used those as a percussion instrument. You can see I actually broken in the process. There were originally five balls that were a perfect unison. Even the most innocuous instruments turned sinister in the hands of Brian Ritzel.
对吧，每个人都知道这个。它就放在你的桌子上。你知道那是那个挂在弦上的不锈钢球摆玩具。但我所做的是，我把它用作……我用它来创造这些节奏，嗯，嗯，你大脑中的突触活动之类的东西。并且对这些进行了不同的处理，将它们用作打击乐器。你可以看到我在这个过程中其实把它弄坏了。原本有五个完美同频的小球。在布赖恩·赖泽尔手中，即使是最无害的乐器也变得险恶起来。
These slay bells I just used in this first episode of Hannibal because I had snails and I had these macro shots of snails. But really it's C, slave-o. And you know, I can go on and on. David Slade calls the sound design of Hannibal free associative. They look at the footage and talk about the characters and the feelings they're trying to evoke from each scene and design from there. The big bad guy in Hannibal is of course Hannibal Lecter, but Wilgram also is wrestling with
这些铃铛我只是用在了《汉尼拔》的第一集里，因为我有蜗牛，而且我有蜗牛的微距镜头。但实际上它是C大调铃铛。你知道的，我可以滔滔不绝说个不停。大卫·斯雷德称《汉尼拔》的声音设计是自由联想的。他们看着素材，谈论角色以及他们试图从每个场景中唤起的情感，并从那里开始设计。《汉尼拔》中的大坏蛋当然是汉尼拔·莱克特，但威尔·格雷厄姆也在与
his own demons. He has dreamlike visions of a demon they call the Windigo that represents both the evil of Hannibal and the evil growing inside Wilgram. One of the characters that developed over time was the Wendigo character, which is the bassist of horrors. And we wanted a sound that indicated the coming of that character. That sound, I knew it was circular. We didn't know why, but we knew that was right. And...
他自己的心魔作斗争。他有着梦幻般的幻象，看到了一个被称为温迪戈的恶魔，它既代表了汉尼拔的邪恶，也代表了在威尔·格雷厄姆体内不断滋长的邪恶。随着时间推移发展出的角色之一是温迪戈角色，它是恐怖之本。我们需要一个能预示那个角色降临的声音。那个声音，我知道它是环形的。我们不知道为什么，但我们知道那是对的。而且……
I took what David said literally, and I got a bullroar, but basically it's a piece of wood on a string. It's one of the oldest instruments, but it sounds incredible. You spin it in a circular manner and in doing so it slices through the air creating this sort of sound. Once we put it against the picture we knew it was the last time. It's very physical sounding, sort of cutting through the air, spinning around your head, making it surreal, yet also very physical. I also did things to that sound.
我字面意思地理解了大卫的话，我弄来了一个牛吼器，但基本上它就是一根系在绳子上的木头。它是最古老的乐器之一，但它听起来不可思议。你以环形的方式挥舞它，这样做它就会切开空气，发出这种声音。一旦我们将它与画面匹配，我们就知道就是它了。它听起来非常具有物理感，有点像切开空气，在你的头顶旋转，让它显得超现实，但同时也非常具有物理感。我还对那个声音做了一些处理。
I pitched it down, I pitched it up to make it scarier. Well, mission accomplished, guys, because I'm creeped up, f**k out. Rishi Keishirui is the creator of Song Exploder, which I am very proud to say is now a member of the Raditopia collective. I'm so excited. Song Exploder is one of my favorite podcasts and the premise is just perfect. Musicians take apart their songs piece by piece to tell the story of how they were made. If you've never heard Song Exploder before, I want to present what I think is my favorite episode so far featuring John Roderick of the long winters, but I have
我把它降调，升调，让它听起来更恐怖。好吧，任务完成了，伙计们，因为我被吓得魂飞魄散。瑞希凯什·赫威是《歌曲解密》的创作者，我非常自豪地宣布，它现在是Radiotopia联盟的成员。我太兴奋了。《歌曲解密》是我最喜欢的播客之一，它的构思简直完美。音乐家们一小段一小段地拆解他们的歌曲，讲述它们是如何创作出来的故事。如果你从未听过《歌曲解密》，我想推荐我认为目前我最喜欢的一集，由超长冬天乐队（The Long Winters）的约翰·罗德里克出演，但我很难
a hard time picking a favorite. I really think you should just download them all and pick your own favorite. Now from Radio Topia, this is Song Exploder. My fellow Americans, this day he's brought terrible news and great sadness to our country. At 9 o'clock this morning, mission control in Houston lost contact with our space shuttle Columbia. A short time later, debris was seen falling from the skies above Texas. The Columbia's lost. There are no survivors. That was President George W. Bush addressing the nation on February 1st 2003.
挑出一集最喜欢的。我真的觉得你应该把它们全部下载下来，挑选你自己的最爱。现在，来自RadioTopia，这里是《歌曲解密》。我同胞们，今天给我们的国家带来了可怕的消息和巨大的悲伤。今天上午9点，休斯顿任务控制中心失去了与我们哥伦比亚号航天飞机的联系。不久之后，人们看到德克萨斯州上空有碎片坠落。哥伦比亚号失事了。机上无人生还。那是2003年2月1日乔治·W·布什总统向全国发表的讲话。
A couple years later John Roderick, singer and songwriter of the long winters recorded a song about the space shuttle Columbia on that day as it broke apart while re-entering the Earth's atmosphere. It's called The Commander Things Allowed. This episode is made from an interview I did with John Roderick in front of a live audience in Seattle about how and why he made this song. I am John Roderick. I had my pilot's license when I was 17. My dad was a small plane pilot. And that was the way my dad, it was one of the ways that we bonded, was in a small plane, you know, trying to make it over a mountain range. So I had a lot of experience in planes.
几年后，超长冬天乐队的歌手兼词曲作者约翰·罗德里克录制了一首歌，关于哥伦比亚号航天飞机在重返地球大气层时解体那一天的情景。这首歌叫做《指挥官心声》（The Commander Thinks Aloud）。这一集剪辑自我对约翰·罗德里克的采访，采访是在西雅图的现场观众面前进行的，内容关于他是如何以及为什么要创作这首歌。我是约翰·罗德里克。我17岁时就有了飞行员执照。我爸爸是一名小型飞机飞行员。那是和我爸爸建立感情的一种方式，是在一架小型飞机里，你知道的，试图飞越山脉。所以我有很多飞机的经验。
I always love to fly. And when the nose comes off the ground, I always feel a charge. I didn't want to be a person that was anxious about flying. Well, at that point in 2005, I guess, we were still pretty close to 9-11, and the space shuttle disaster followed pretty close on the heats.
我一直都很喜欢飞行。当机头离开地面时，我总是感到一种冲动。我不想成为一个对飞行感到焦虑的人。好吧，在2005年的那个时候，我想，我们离9-11事件还挺近的，而航天飞机灾难紧随其后。
But also there were all those smaller disaster crashes. The Alaska Airlines crash that happened off the coast of California where they lost their vertical stabilizer, the jack screw one. The pilots were aware there was a problem, everyone was aware there was a problem, it just flew around and then flipped upside down and plummeted into the ocean. And then there was the one off of Long Island where maybe the gas tank exploded and then there was that lear jet that lost compression and everybody in it gone until it ran on a gas. And all of these disasters stuck with me,
但同时也有所有那些较小的灾难坠机事故。发生在加州海岸外的阿拉斯加航空公司的坠机事故，他们的垂直安定面脱落了，就是那个千斤顶螺丝的问题。飞行员们知道出了问题，所有人都知道出了问题，它只是到处乱飞，然后翻转过来，一头栽进海洋中。然后是长岛附近的那起事故，可能是油气箱爆炸了，接着是那架失去压缩功能的里尔喷气机，机上所有人都在耗尽燃料前离世了。所有这些灾难都留在了我的记忆中，
particularly the ones where there was a sense that the people on board knew that they were lost, but they were still alive. The unfolding, dawning realization like, you know, we're not getting out of this. And what's your reaction in that situation, do you scream? You probably don't.
尤其是那些让人觉得机上人员知道自己已经完了，但他们依然还活着的感觉。那种逐渐展开、渐渐意识到的感觉，就像，“你知道的，我们逃不出去了。”而在那种情况下你的反应是什么，你会尖叫吗？你可能不会。
Probably everybody is really calm in that situation. And so I pictured the astronauts on reentry. They knew there was something wrong with their ship. They were worried about it, but everybody had convinced them it was going to be fine. And they're performing their duties, they are having the peak experience of their lives. And maybe one of the peak human experiences like we are coming back to Earth, having just like looked down at Earth and had that, feeling how beautiful that kind of dumb little stuff is. The beauty of the mundane, right, like boys and girls and cars and dogs and birds on lawns,
可能在这种情况下每个人都很冷静。所以我脑海中浮现出宇航员在重返大气层时的画面。他们知道他们的飞船出了点问题。他们对此感到担心，但所有人都让他们确信一切都会好起来的。他们在履行职责，他们正在经历一生中最巅峰的体验。也许是人类最巅峰的体验之一，比如我们正返回地球，刚刚向下俯瞰地球，并有了那种感觉——那种愚蠢的小东西是多么美丽。平凡之美，对吧，就像男孩和女孩、汽车、狗和草坪上的鸟儿一样，
like seeing it maybe, like no one else would ever see. Boys and girls in cars, dogs and birds on lawns. From here I can touch the sign. Did you sit down with the idea that you were going to write a song about the spatial disaster? Yeah, but I didn't know how it was going to work. Every once in a while you get one as a songwriter where you sit down at your instrument, you have an idea, you have a first line, you sing it and compose the entire song in an hour, and then you go, I don't know where that came from. I resisted piano lessons as a kid, but sometime in high school, I started to sit at the piano
就像看到它一样，就像其他人永远不会看到的那样。草坪上的男孩女孩、汽车、狗和鸟。从这里我可以触摸到标志。你坐下来的时候就有了要写一首歌关于航天飞机灾难的想法吗？是的，但我不知道它会如何成型。作为一个词曲作者，偶尔你会遇到这种情况：你坐在乐器前，你有一个想法，你有了第一句歌词，你唱出来并在一个小时内创作完整首歌，然后你会想，我不知道这灵感是从哪来的。我小时候抗拒钢琴课，但在高中时期的某个时候，我开始坐在钢琴前
voluntarily when no one was home and try and figure it out. And I got as far as you could go if you were just practicing for 11 minutes at a time. And I didn't really learn the piano until I was in my 30s. Learned the piano as much as I know it now. In the early 90s, in Seattle especially, there was a mentality that you didn't want to over-learn your instrument Right because that was going to affect the authenticity of your feelings And I embraced that hook line and sinker
当家里没人的时候主动去弹，并试着摸索它。如果每次只练习11分钟的话，我也只能学到这种程度了。直到我三十多岁时，我才真正学会了钢琴。把钢琴学到了我现在所知道的程度。在90年代初，特别是在西雅图，有一种心态，你不想把你的乐器学得过头，对吧？因为那会影响你情感的真实性。而我全盘接受了这一点。
So the producer of this track was Tucker Martine Tucker had a just a stand-up parlor piano in his living room That was recorded in his living room. Now we would probably just record at one measure and loop it. But at the time I had to sit and play it for five minutes and then I would get to the end and he'd be like, hmmm. Let's hit it again. Let's hit it again. Eric Corison, Long Winner's bass player, and my chief musical partner. He sat down at the microchord, which is not an instrument he knew, but he worked with
所以这首歌的制作人是特克·马丁。特克在他的起居室里放着一架立式客厅钢琴。那是他的起居室里录制的。现在我们可能只会录制一个小节然后循环播放。但在当时，我必须坐下来弹奏五分钟，然后等我弹到最后，他会说，嗯。我们再来一次。我们再来一次。埃里克·科里森，超长冬天乐队的贝斯手，也是我主要的音乐合作伙伴。他坐在微型合成器前，这不是他熟悉的乐器，但他摆弄了
it for a little bit and figured it out. There are five or six moments in the song that without Eric's part, it would be so much less of a complete work. His part is very cinematic. As the song unfolds, it just starts to go sideways and every successive verse, stuff is starting to break. Most of the long-winner songs are about relationships and they are
一会儿就搞懂了。这首歌中有五六个地方，如果没有埃里克的部分，它作为完整作品的逊色就会非常多。他的部分非常有电影感。随着歌曲的展开，它开始偏离轨道，在每一个接连的诗节中，东西开始破裂。超长冬天乐队的大多数歌曲都是关于人际关系的，而且它们
intentionally difficult to parse because they're meant to communicate in an emotional language rather than in a literal language. And so as I was writing this song, I As I made my way through the emotional story I was trying to tell I did arrive at a place where I was like I need to arrive at a place where I was like I need to give a clue here somewhere. The crew compartment's breaking up. I was embarrassed to say the crew compartment's breaking up because I felt like it was too literal. And so to say the crew compartment's breaking up, the first time I went through it, I was just like, ah, you know, but it needed it. The crew compartment's breaking up.
故意很难解析，因为它们旨在用情感语言而不是字面语言来交流。所以当我写这首歌的时候，我……当我经历我试图讲述的情感故事时，我确实到了一个地方，我想我需要……我需要在这里某个地方给出一个线索。乘员舱正在解体。我很不好意思说乘员舱正在解体，因为我觉得它太字面化了。所以为了说乘员舱正在解体，第一次我唱过去的时候，我只是觉得，啊，你知道的，但它需要这个。乘员舱正在解体。
The crew compartment's breaking up. And the thing was, you sing it once, the second time everybody gets it, the third time they've heard it now, the fourth time they're like, okay, all right. Fifth, the sixth time, it heard it now, the fourth time they're like okay all right, fifth, the sixth time it starts to get annoying and then a new kind of gravity enters in seventh time. You start to feel the emotion. Breaking up the crew compartments breaking up. And when I perform at live, if I'm not careful,
乘员舱正在解体。事情是这样的，你唱了一遍，第二遍每个人都明白了，第三遍他们现在听到了，第四遍他们会觉得，好吧，行吧。第五遍、第六遍，现在听到了，第四遍他们会觉得好吧，行吧，第五遍、第六遍开始变得有点烦人，然后在第七遍时，一种新的重力介入了。你开始感受到那种情感。解体，乘员舱正在解体。当我在现场表演时，如果不小心，
I will start to cry during that part. Those are real violins. We tried to get a little string quartet to come and we ran several passes at it. We took that and played it double speed. And they did their own version of this kind of swarm of bees. So we didn't have a drummer and it was like who should we get? Should we call that one guy? He was like, or I could get the best drummer in the country. Any producer would make that choice if he had Matt Chamberlain's number. And Tucker did.
我会在那个部分开始哭泣。那些是真正的提琴。我们试图找一个小弦乐四重奏来，我们试跑了好几遍。我们拿了那个录音并以双倍速播放。他们做了他们自己版本的这种“蜜蜂群”。所以我们没有鼓手，当时的想法是谁来？我们应该叫那个家伙吗？他当时说，或者我可以找全国最好的鼓手。任何制作人如果有马特·张伯伦的电话号码，都会做出这个选择。而特克有。
And he managed to not just introduce swing into it, but make this piano part, which on its own is very square and on top of the beat. And he played to it and introduced swing to it, played a little bit behind and a little bit with this tremendous sort of breath and energy. And watching it all happen was a revelation to me as a musician. I understood how much I had to learn. So what Matt did, he came in, he set up his drums and he had one microphone that he pulled out of a bag
他不仅成功地将摇摆乐引入其中，而且让这个钢琴部分——它本身非常死板且刚好卡在拍子上——随之演奏并引入了摇摆感，稍微落后一点点并带着巨大的呼吸感和能量弹奏。看着这一切发生对我这个音乐家来说是一个启示。我明白了我有那么多东西要学。所以马特做的是，他走进来，架起他的鼓，他从包里掏出一个麦克风
and set up himself. And we all just were watching him, like you would watch a black panther that came into your kitchen. It's like, what's it gonna do? And he put the microphone in front of his drums and he was like, okay, you know, record me. And so he plays for about a minute and then he's like, play that back for me.
然后自己架设起来。我们所有人都只是看着他，就像你看一只走进厨房的美洲豹一样。心想，它要做什么？他把麦克风放在鼓前面，然后说，好了，你知道的，录音吧。于是他弹奏了一分钟左右，然后他说，把那个放给我听听。
He listens to the track for a minute. And then he stands up, he walks around and he moves the microphone imperceptibly. Sits back down and says, roll it. And he plays all the way through the track. And I was listening to it and going like, you know, I'm the songwriter and kind of the main guy here. And I was like, yeah, that was pretty good. I mean, I've got some comments. And we got to the end and he was like, okay, roll it again.
他听了一分钟的音轨。然后他站起来，四处走动，几乎察觉不到地移动了麦克风。重新坐下并说，开始吧。他一路弹完整首音轨。我当时听着它，心想（你知道的，我是词曲作者也是这里的主要人物），我当时想，是的，那挺不错的。我的意思是，我有一些意见。等我们到了结尾，他却说，好吧，再录一遍。
You know, and didn't wait to hear any comments from the songwriter, which is like, all right. He played through it again, and I was like, no, it was really interesting. You know, this kind of variation. And he was like, give it to me again. He did that five times. And then he's like, all right, you know, I'm coming into the control room. And he comes in, he sits down and he's like all right you know I'm coming into the control room and he comes and he sits down and he's like okay pan those five tracks hard left middle left center middle
你知道的，没有等词曲作者的任何意见，就像是，好吧。他又弹了一遍，而我当时想，不，这真的很有趣。你知道的，这种变化。而他说，再来一次。他那样做了五次。然后他说，好吧，你知道的，我要进控制室了。他走进来，坐下来，然后说，好吧，你知道的，我要进控制室了，他走进来，坐下来，然后说，好吧，把这五个音轨分别向左潘到头、中左、正中、中
right hard right in the order that I recorded them five mono drum parts and he had the four side that there are drum fills that start on one track and continue through all five tracks. So, you know, you hear about guys and you're like, oh, that guy's amazing! But this was something truly amazing. As part of his drum kit, I forgot to mention, he has a piece of rusty sheet metal. Just attached to a clamp. And he starts to go up to this sheet metal like and all of that sheet metal noise that he was creating. The whole end of the
右、向右潘到头，按照我录音的顺序，五个单声道鼓部件，他有四面，有些鼓花是从一个音轨开始一直延续到所有五个音轨的。所以，你知道的，你听说过一些家伙，你会想，哦，那家伙太棒了！但这真的是非常了不起的事情。作为他的鼓组的一部分，我忘了提，他有一块生锈的金属板。只是绑在一个夹子上。他开始走向这块金属板，像……以及他创造的所有金属板噪音。整首歌的结尾，
tune where the spaceship is coming apart he was making that sound on the rusty metal. He had a vision of the song that I didn't even have. You know, the title of the song wasn't clear until right about this point in the recording. And so then, if the commanders, you know, thinking aloud, why is he telling us this story? ZI WANTED TO BRING HOME ZI WANTED TO BRING HOME TO YOU That's his last word, I guess. Do you have a sense of who he was addressing when he says that?
也就是宇宙空间站在解体的地方，他就是在那个生锈的金属上发出那种声音。他对这首歌的构想甚至是我所没有的。你知道的，这首歌的标题直到录音的这个时候才真正清晰起来。所以然后，如果指挥官，你知道的，在自言自语，他为什么要给我们讲这个故事？我想带回家，我想带回家给你。我想那是他的遗言，我猜。你知道当他说这话时，他是在对谁说话吗？
I don't publicly out myself as a utopian and a people lover because it's not my brand. But I'm an idealist and I love humanity and I imagine us as all in a ship together and with a common cause. And space exploration seems like the ultimate expression of human beings doing their best work. So I imagine he's bringing that back to us, all of us, something that if we could only share that the simple feeling of just like like why the hell do we go up into space we go up into space to bring back that little tantalizing like vision of
我不会公开将自己标榜为乌托邦主义者或博爱主义者，因为这不是我的个人标签。但我是个理想主义者，我热爱人类，我把我们想象成都在同一艘船上，有着共同的事业。太空探索似乎是人类尽其所能的终极体现。所以我猜他把那带回给我们，带回给我们所有人，如果我们能仅仅分享那种简单的感觉——就像——我们到底为什么要上太空？我们上太空是为了带回那个诱人的愿景：
the earth being a borderless place full of birds and boys and girls And now here's the commander things allowed by the long winters in its entirety. Boys and girls in cars, dogs and birds are long From here I can touch the sun Yeah, yeah With your jacket on I feel we're being born The tropical capricorn is below Yeah Yeah Yeah
地球是一个充满鸟儿、男孩和女孩的无国界的地方。现在是超长冬天乐队的完整版《指挥官心声》。草坪上的男孩女孩、汽车、狗和鸟从这里我可以触摸到太阳，耶，耶，穿着你的夹克，我觉得我们正在诞生，热带摩羯座在下方，耶，耶，耶。
Yeah We start above the pole Still your face is young As we feel our weight return Yeah Yeah The trail of shit takes stars The horses call the storm Because the earth contains the charm Yeah, yeah, yeah The radio is on The year is on
耶，我们在极地之上开始，但你的脸依然年轻，当我们感觉到重力回归，耶，耶，留下的星尘，马儿呼唤风暴，因为大地蕴含着魅力，耶，耶，耶，收音机开着，年份在流转。
And Houston knows the score Can you feel it with all of my own time? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Oh Break it now Criminal components Break it now Scythe, Criminal components Break it now Scythe, Criminal components Break it now Scythe, Criminal components Reckless breaking the sun
而休斯敦了解情况，你能用我所有的全部时间去感受它吗？耶，耶，耶，耶，哦，现在打破它，犯罪组件，现在打破它，镰刀，犯罪组件，现在打破它，镰刀，犯罪组件，现在打破它，镰刀，犯罪组件，鲁莽地打破太阳。
Declaring requirements Reckless, I'm just ready ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ The Rishikesh Rwae is the creator of Song Exploder, now from Radio Topia. Find out more at songexploder.net. 99% Invisible is Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan,, Avery Troubleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arkson, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, we're on Twitter, Instagram, Tumblr, and Spotify too, but if you want to tell a fanable, that's a fan of the show Hannibal about our show.
宣告需求，鲁莽，我只是准备好了。瑞希凯什·赫威是《歌曲解密》的创作者，现由RadioTopia呈现。了解更多信息请访问 songexploder.net。《99% Invisible》的成员有凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特罗布尔曼以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的一家建筑和室内设计公司 Arkson 的办公室里。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞这个节目，我们也在 Twitter、Instagram、Tumblr 和 Spotify 上，但如果你想告诉一个粉丝，一个《汉尼拔》节目的粉丝关于我们节目的事。
The best place to send them is 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
发送他们的最佳网址是 99pi.org。Radio Topia。来自 PRX。来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。